Isaac Newton let me just look at you
read his writings the hair stands up on
I don't have hair there but if I did it
would stand up on the back of my neck
you read his rider the man was connected
to the universe in ways that I've never
seen another human being connected it's
kind of spooky actually
he discovers the laws of optics figures
out that white light is composed of
colors that's kind of freaky right there
you take your colors of the rainbow put
them back together yet white light again
that freaked out the artists of the day
how does that work red orange yellow
green blue violet gives you white the
laws of optics he discovers the laws of
motion and the universal law of
gravitation then a friend of his says
well why do these orbits of the planets
why are they in the shape of an ellipse
sort of flattened circle why aren't they
some other shape and so you know I can't
I don't know I'll get back to you so it
goes goes home comes back a couple
months later here here's why they're
actually conic sections sections of a
cone that you cut and they said well how
did you find this out how did you
determine this well I had to invent
integral and differential calculus to
determine this then he turned 26
then he turned 26
we got people slogging through calculus
in college just to learn what it is that
Isaac Newton invented on a dare
practically so that that's my man